hey guys I'm Tiffany Smith I'm Kristian
harloff and we are back here at the
Fandango Studios and Tiffany one of the
most anticipated movies next year is the
Power Rangers movie and we are joined by
the cast guys thank you party and I'm
gonna totally embarrass myself here and
say I used to watch Power Rangers like
every single day after school I loved it
so inviting that's me so these was a
support groups I found each other yes
admitting now hi my name is Becky G and
I have an addiction to power that's what
I was gonna ask what was your guys
connection to the Power Rangers before
becoming Rangers yourself um for me very
similar to yours I remember it's just
played a huge part of my life waking up
every morning before school watching
Power Rangers while eating my cereal or
waffles
being like cool time to go to school um
yeah and I always wanted to be the
yellow Power Ranger which is so crazy to
me because how I am so for me I had a
connection to the old Power Ranger
before a new Power Rangers even existed
my first action figure was the yellow
Power Rangers oh my barf remember who
please me for separating me from my
family because she forced me to move
overseas oh wow
and so I played with this thing all the
time no seriously I didn't know what it
was it was the coolest thing the first
action figure I've ever seen like the
most the best toy I had yeah the joints
everything moves right in you so then
when you were going out for this role
then that right away the yellow one was
the one you were gearing for immediately
actually actually I was the pink today
oh yeah it was either the yellow or the
pink they said oh oh yeah it's a little
bit too big for this is good this goes
this way but this goes through it to me
to where like I did not watch this I
just missed the power that's why you're
on the chair by on the corner I know
it's a note but what I will tell you is
that I've seen so many fans that cannot
wait to see for me what I want to know
as someone who was not a didn't watch it
growing up what is different about the
tone of the television show then the
tone of this particular film I think
it's very different but it keeps the
true essence of what Power Rangers
okay I think we know we're stepping into
some pretty big shoes to fill you know
power ranges is very established and has
its own fandom in itself the og fans and
in this movie there's a lot of what do
we call them the Easter eggs Easter eggs
yes yeah it's a hard rock bands but for
people who probably never really had an
interaction with Power Rangers before
they will fall in love with these
characters that were playing because
there's so much depth to them and so
much taralacey reimagining is a reboot
you know I think if I can speak to that
I mean I didn't really watch it growing
up so for me the whole idea was it was
more about the concept of what it means
to be a superhero and what that means to
a lot of people yeah so I think in this
film whilst appealing to a contemporary
or you know a more contemporary audience
we still have the heart of the 90s
through Power Rangers and all of those
fans and hopefully we can juggle both
and really really yeah you know gain
some support from both things I mean
there's a lot of pressure on us and we
feel the responsibility from to the fans
yeah right and I mean I just want to say
stay calm we got really excited not sure
it's gonna be good there's there's gonna
be some magic to this um like it's a
coming-of-age story isn't it is it if
that's yet that's basically what it is
and every like each each character has
their own individual journey yeah but
it's it's about all of us together yeah
and everyone has to invest in these
characters you know we have an
opportunity to to really delve into you
know more deeper and more layered
character and they'll tell you but
that's essentially how you grab audience
said you know if you want to offer
everybody its universally relatable in
the sense definitely everybody the
pathway to manhood pathway to womanhood
everything you experience throughout
high school sure you know there's it
that's relatable on a university and
it's funny you say that because it's
kind of the what I've heard you guys can
speak to this whether this is true or
not but um that there's cuffs
I've been some comparisons to Sam
Raimi's spider-man like the way the tone
in that first movie the first and second
film like that's kind of what this tone
could be and that sounds very
encouraging if that's indeed
I think it's it's a fun movie it has a
lot of energy obviously it's an action
movie because they're superheroes but I
think what's really awesome about is
there's a lot of heart to it as well
like we talked about how cool it is that
you can see superheroes be friends we're
superheroes together as like our own
little family and like you got the guys
you got the girls and we're all working
together and I think it's really awesome
to see it's going to be really inspiring
to the younger generation yeah no
totally I agree and also a big shout out
to the director because I was saying
earlier today we are friends on and off
screen yeah but I think he was their
link going bring that to the screen
that's why
well that's gotta said everyday and have
fun it's like it's like working with a
friend - Dean yeah wheat he's what's the
kid when did you guys feel like you had
that chemistry because it is really
about the friends really it sounds quite
easy we didn't knew we actually just
realized we didn't do any kind of
chemistry test together we didn't know
about each other but we made it kind of
a priority within ourselves to make sure
that we got to know each other and
everything in connected and sup yeah on
whatsapp we had our little whatsapp your
2016 Ranger crew and um yeah the oh my
gosh I don't wanna see that no you know
because I was I was touring you got you
in China you in Australia you are you
pal soldier and then RJ is just like
hanging out and setting other crazy
funny videos cuz he's hilarious so we're
all like in different parts of the world
sending each other like this is what I'm
doing today and it's like different
times but it was just so good I was kind
of funny because Becky would be like
this is what I'm doing they were like a
stadium like I mean I've been like this
is what I'm doing today like with white
children really yeah well speaking from
all the world there we have a lot of
people watching right now and I wanted
to shout out to CJ who asked out of all
the Power Rangers concepts overall what
is the most influential for you overall
out of all the Power Ranger concepts so
out of all the Power Rangers two
concepts overall what is the most
influential for you so CJ its CJ right
so she J I'm not sure what what what
concepts you're looking for but the
concept that's most important for me is
the concept of togetherness yeah it's
just embodied message of Power Ranger
we said before about how how it's
different from the TV show like you can
be a hardcore fan you can go back to the
original TV show and they can trace it
back to the original Japanese TV show
but what's neat underneath all that the
core the Power Rangers yeah like how
it's just Power Rangers now it's the
unity and it's togetherness there's a
lot of superhero teams out there but the
Power Rangers vigil yeah we're not we're
nothing except for a team like we're
together and when the hours mean way not
we're not initially friends as
characters innate and that friendship is
formed and then through that that
togetherness come yeah you want us to
get it oh man it's yeah right sure I we
are here with the cast of the upcoming
Power Rangers movie and the other thing
that's bringing back somebody who was
involved in the original show is Bryan
Cranston yeah Nev Ryan Castle bacon or
turn and then we also we've seen some
speaking about concepts we saw a whole
set oh man we saw a great picture we're
gonna show of Rita they're just the way
they look because it does seem like you
guys were saying you're gonna take
elements from the original series and
that give us kind of a new spin so fans
should be getting excited for yeah that
[ __ ] yeah there's definitely something
I'm excited
oh you spoke so tell me think about it I
mean obviously Elizabeth finds her
costume I mean she graduate Leah Maisie
yeah new thing she really new energy and
new viably yes Chevy me being so new to
the acting scene
I think it was very inspiring to see her
make every decision so so strategically
for her character and even being
involved to the costume in the
prosthetics and saying okay when she's
in this phase where is she not only in a
mental state of mind but in a physical
state you know and the way she would
interact with us like I didn't have a
choice but to feel scared yeah so even
when the camera wasn't rolling and she's
standing there in front of me it felt so
real fearless yeah yeah and we learn a
lot from that
yeah well and talking about just the
costumes what was it like for you guys
the first time putting on with us we
were together we were hungry so that was
one thing when I'm angry when I'm
agree it's over so we're both standing
there for three hours because the first
fitting was they had to place everything
exactly where it needed to go and it
wasn't it something was actually done we
were like oh damn
we're power and you ask why oh the mask
yes what you say it's when you put the
Moscow in Babel shoes that I mean he
gives you something there's that I don't
know it's when you put the masks on and
then you you feel it and then you see
other people looking at you yeah through
the mask and you're like do you need
saving
yes well you guys you guys mentioned
unity and how you guys have all come
together well we've got a little gain
here that's gonna test that unity we're
gonna see how good you guys are I'm
gonna get up Tiffani you explain the
rules while we do a little bit of
maneuvering no we're gonna have the hot
seat over here and it's a little game
that I feel like you are very excited
about it
don't let it say coffee first yeah oh
you got all right you wanna sit okay so
we're gonna play heads up you're gonna
take one of these fandango papers out of
this Oh put it on your forehead don't
look at it you guys ever we all we're
gonna help paper we all have to help her
guess what's on her phone whoops sorry
give her clothes g-girl I'm not gonna
yeah wait Knicks delight which am I on
the right side no upside down okay
oh man okay upside down so yeah yeah
yeah okay oh yeah now we start yelling
on stuff without her saying yes Aubrey
she is a Ghostbuster how's McCall nice
all right off the bat oh yeah get out
there we just do one and then
rotating okay rotating with names and
things that's why we're here we're here
we're gonna help you well here we go sat
down for this time okay okay uh-oh
pull me back in hold me back sure mom
grind oh yeah what Frances
Fredo now remember we did this for
Easter with our feet yeah and I just
know that the right way right is no no
we should all get a new appreciate any
suggestion let him do this standing
Hagen yeah it's way more hilarious
ready also do what I'm saying okay I'll
sit down to calm my dress of cards in
your office this is what I love this
Baker coming out of the couch I love it
commit me should try one you're like
well you guys are here well you guys
don't even say anything just like know
your books
yep that way okay I'm not I'm not in a
movie oh wow it's a move away you go
Star Wars no you can hug me I'm ready
break it off yeah break it off yeah one
day and they just came out with a new
friends willow frank grillo this guy
really
do something you've known at all
election that Election Day election
something something Election Day just
came out together what do they do they
the mitten guy we can you know you're
doing marriage the same letter again
words yes the merger
boss come back / yeah yeah I want you
guys to say breaking the rule like
slurred yeah we got we got yeah what I
still have to somehow see how good I am
at this do some play this game I'm not
peeking
I'm nervous okay yeah Kristin you're up
I'm up
I'll go take this off of that ah yes I
like yes yes okay the rock [ __ ] tryna
see a fight in but engine starts crying
Lucy I thought Nicolas Cage are we do
one more like you're up okay down you
got it your ass one egg yellow flash
whining a movie camera in the Fandango
studio night Jules
yeah yeah wait I feel like scuse me I'm
gonna say that I feel like she's one of
the best ones alleged okay I got woody
woody you got Woody and Buzz result
go on someone else okay
we're done thank you guys so much for
joining us Power Rangers gonna be coming
out make sure that you check it out here
look at that's toys flying in good show
game to play with us we want to give you
some presents almost is it ok so make
sure that you guys check out the Power
Rangers next year when it hits theaters
guys thanks again for joining us today
Tiffany where else can they find us yeah
make sure you guys follow me on all
social media because we've got great
stuff coming out of San Diego comic-con
all week long we'll see you guys later
you